[музика]
вітаємо це програма У фокусі Європа я
Лара бабалола Ласкаво просимо до
програми землетрусу у Туреччині та Сирії
залишили по собі величезні руйнування
постраждало багато міст і сіл будинки і
будівлі перетворилися на руїни
повідомляється про десятки тисяч
загиблих і очікується Що жертв буде
більше оскільки рятувальні операції
поступово переходять у відновлювальні
роботи для декого землетрус - це ще один
жорсткий поворот долі мазар із сирій Він
утік до Туреччини разом із мільйонами
інших рятуючись від громадянської війни
мазару оселився у місті антак'я він
почувався в безпеці від насильства яке
вже більше 10 років не дає спокою Сирії
але тепер місце де Чоловік знайшов
притулок перетворилося на зону
катастрофи
сестру ми зараз це все було знайдено він
кидається до руїни які донедавна були її
квартирою
сирійські друзі мазара в Туреччині
знайшли це все та її чоловіка під
уламками другого поверху
вони обоє загинули мазар боявся
найгіршого
він кілька днів без успішно шукав ознаки
життя у цій будівлі вантакті на
південному сході Туреччини
тепер у нього є лише впевненість
будь ласка нікому не кажи ми ще нікому
не говорили Спочатку ми їх дістанемо
але операція і з визволення виявляється
складною мазар і його друзі повільно
просуваються уперед за допомогою
позиченого відбійного молотка
вони навіть не сподіваються на допомогу
від влади
друг приніс вовняну ковдру щоб загорнути
тіло
пізніше за всем поховають належним чином
ми дійшли до спальні Спочатку ми
побачили частину чоловіка моєї сестри
а потім її саму
вони лежали обнявшись перед смертю
мазар Втік від Громадянської війни у
Сирії до Туреччини разом із батьками
братами та сестрами
зараз він живе у Стамбулі його сестра
севсен навчала дітей сирійських біженців
в атакі
[музика]
Моя сестра була такою хорошою людиною
сповненою любов'ю
Мені дуже шкода що вона померла
Але така Воля Аллаха
Анталія біля сирійського кордону
землетрус зруйнував близько половини
міста
лише через кілька днів почалися перші
відновлювальні роботи
до землетрусу тут проживало близько 300
тисяч сирійських біженців
наразі невідомо скільки з них є жертвами
але мазар і його друзі розповідають що
по той бік кордону у Сирії ситуація
виглядає набагато гірше
чимало його родичів імовірно втратили
все
ніби війни були недостатньо Люди там не
отримують практично ніякої допомоги
[музика]
тут принаймні час від часу хтось
приходить і приносить щось поїсти чи
пропонує свою допомогу
близько 7 годин пішло на те щоб дістати
тіла севцем та її чоловіка
ми приїхали сюди щоб жити в безпеці усе
склалося Інакше І тепер Нам доведеться з
цим жити
тіла це все і махмуда відвозять від
будинку в антакті де вони мріяли про
Мирне життя
після землетрусу в Туреччині зростає
хвиля гніву уряд Туреччини вже
впроваджував суворіший будівельні норми
після руйнівного землетрусу що стався
понад 20 років тому але Ці правила не
завжди застосовувались на практиці і
зрізання кутів у будівництві схоже було
звичною справою зараз держава опинилася
під шквалом критики за нездатній
забезпечити дотримання цих правил
безпеки
те що колись було сімейним будинком
тепер лежить у руїнах а вранці 7 лютого
землетрус зруйнував будинок шахінів мати
тут же шахіна опинилася під уламками і
отримала серйозні травми через деякий
час а вона померла
немає слів щоб передати ці Відчуття і цю
ситуацію
Ми відвідали село Токар на південному
сході Туреччини
це віддалений регіони люди тут живуть
бідно
одній зі зруйнованих будівель був лише
рік будинок сім'ї шахіні був старішим
розповідає тонжей його батько якого не
було вдома в ніч катастрофи тільки
оглядаючи уланки розуміє наскільки
неякісними були будівельні матеріали
погляньте сюди ці тонкі сталеві стрижні
повинні були якось утримувати несучі
опори разом це справді мало б стати для
нас уроком але люди звертають на це
увагу лише тоді коли самі зіткнуться з
цим щойно більш вщухає вони знову стають
легковажними
ці матеріали мали бути перевірені владою
Сподіваюся відтепер за будівництвом у
цих зонах підвищеного ризику стежитимуть
суворіше
покладатися на турецьку будівельну владу
чи ні це вже Інше питання але Хасан АК
сумбур має свої сумніви він очолює
палату інженерів-будівельників у
портовому місті адана його телефони не
припиняють дзвонити після землетрусу
експертиза його команди користується
великим попитом оскільки мешканці хочуть
щоб їхні будинки перевірили вони більше
не довіряють державній владі оглядаючи
житловий масив що постраждав від
землетрусу аксумгур повсюди виявляє
тріщини на фасадах
це можуть бути просто тріщини на
штукатурці
поки не пошкоджено несучі частини
будівля все ще може бути придатною для
проживання
Але мені важко судити з першого погляду
уряд Застерігає критиків своєї політики
щодо землетрусів не поширювати так звані
фейкові новини але такі люди як аксулур
знають що уряд у закони в мільйони
будівель які були побудовані без дозволу
а багато інших були зведені вищими ніж
дозволено
йдеться про бізнес про прибуток
Подивіться ці квартири продаються в
еквіваленті за 250 тисяч євро щонайменше
заходи безпеки не можуть конкурувати
жадібністю до наживи
смертоносні землетруси можуть
повторитися в будь-який момент
попереджає аксумгур жителів Адани але
багато хто здається вже не вірить у це
нам сказали що з нашим будинком все
гаразд але ми повинні дочекатися
знесення сусіднього будинку тоді ми
зможемо повернутися
вони не можуть продовжувати жити так як
жили до цієї катастрофи каже аксунгур
потрібно почати все із чистого аркуша
у зона ризику як ця всі повинні
працювати разом громадяни місту
будівники архітектори і політики Нам
потрібен консенсу щодо реконструкції
якщо це можливо необхідно забезпечити
щоб ми більше ніколи не будували
безпосередньо над лініями розломів
у селі Токар мешканці бояться
повертатися до своїх домівок
Влада виділила селянам один намет ті хто
не зміг отримати місце в ньому
побудували власні із пластикових
брезентів важко сказати Як довго їм
доведеться жити в наметах але всі
погоджуються домівки майбутнього
доведеться будувати інакше
відтепер ми будемо будувати тільки
одноповерхові будинки так як це було
раніше
але безпечніших будівель недостатньо
каже тунджий Шахін
Я сподіваюся що відтепер буде більше
освіти про небезпеку від землетрусів
Тут жив вшановує пам'ять своєї матері на
місцевому кладовищі якби всі серйозно
ставилися до небезпеки від землетрусів
каже він його сім'ї можливо вдалося б
уникнути цієї трагедії
Марія та Андрій кінематографісти з
Білорусі вони використовують своє
мистецтво щоб боротися проти режиму
Александра Лукашенка він при владі вже
майже 30 років фальсифікація виборів
політичні репресії та порушення прав
людини звична справа На їхній
батьківщині Марія та Андрій дають віціч
за допомогою своєї улюбленої зброї
гумору Після кількох сюжетних поворотів
вони оселилися у Берліні німецька
столиця стала ідеальною сценою для
їхнього життя у вигнанні
це європейський Бізон також відомий як
Зубр найбільша дика тварина на
континенті у Швейцарії вони вимерли у
середні віки зараз туди завезли тестовий
статушок перевірити чи зможуть ці
тварини знову жити у природному
середовищі існування у кантоні золоту не
зубрів утримують у закритому просторі
поки що незважаючи на своїх різні
розміри ці ссавці досить миролюбні і
навіть сором’язливі але Чи означає це що
вони зможуть співіснувати з людьми
[музика]
могутні але елегантні
європейські бізони також відомі як зубри
вже кілька місяців пасуться Тут у горах
Юра біля містечка вельшнрор
вони європейські родичі
північноамериканських бізонів
європейські зубри лісові тварини
якщо подивитися спереду То можна
побачити що їхні голови такі ж вузькі як
і тіло Ведмідь від них
північноамериканський різновид живе на
рівнинах вони трохи коротші ширші тому
що там не потрібно бути високим і
струнким
Бенджамін брунер привіз сюди
європейський зубрів із зоопарку їх
випустили у вольєр площею 100 гектарів
де вони сподіваються звикнуть до життя у
дикій природі оскільки до людей їм теж
треба звикати сюди запрошують туристів
але підходити до них або ж торкатися не
можна відстань не менше 50 метрів для
цього існує правило великого пальця
якщо ви витягнути великий палець і він
закриє Зубра то відстань буде приблизно
50 метрів
Звісно це залежить від того наскільки
товстий ваш великий палець або наскільки
широкий Зубр
якщо тварини помічають туристів чи
навіть ідуть до них людям рекомендується
відійти подалі заради власної безпеки а
також для того щоб дати тваринам простір
адже вони повинні жити не залежно від
людини
Через 5 років планується зняти огорожу
навколо вольєра і випустити зубрів на
волю так як вони жили тут колись Це мрія
рейнджера бенджаміна Брунера та
керівника проекту ото хольцганга
колись у Швейцарії водилися європейські
бізони але з часів середньовіччя їх тут
не було вони частина лісу і без них ліс
не повний
Але не всі поділяють цю думку
багато фермерів стурбовані цією ідеєю
Едгар Купер не хоче щоб навколо бродили
дикі тварини Він каже що їм і так
вистачає проблем
повертаються олені вже є вовки і кабани
завдають багато шкоди Нам не потрібно ще
одна дика тварина і особливо Та яку
завезли штучно
літтями на землях сучасної Швейцарії
мешкали європейські зубри поки люди не
винищили їх чому ж не слід відновлювати
тут популяцію зубрів
ну динозаври тут теж колись жили ми
фермер знаємо Як поводяться пасовичні
тварини ми знаємо корів
і Вони намагаються знайти їжу там де це
найлегше ці бізони будуть робити те саме
і прийдуть на наші поля вони їстимуть те
що нам потрібно щоб годувати наших
тварин
і брунер кажуть що програма відновлення
популяції зубів у Швейцарії допоможе
зберегти європейських бізонів на
континенті Тому що їм загрожує вимирання
через хрещування потрібно більше биків
які не споріднені між собою така заміна
допомагає знизити ризик генетичних
захворювань
[музика]
100 років тому їх було лише 12 здатних
до розмноження можна сказати справжній
генетичний дефіцит
Це була найбільша проблема
селекції постійно замінювала всіх боків
популяція знову почала зростати
[музика]
популяція найбільших наземних ссавців
Європи може відновитися рейнджер
Бенджамін брунер переконаний що для
цього є багато місця питання у тому чи
дозволять їм люди
[музика]
у дитинстві мати забороняла йому
займатися цим видом спорту але це не
завадило ванні одера здійснити свою мрію
стати зіркою мотокросу італійський
гонщик один із найуспішніших вендустрії
за свою кар'єру побував по всьому світу
і не лише шанувальники цього виду спорту
можуть побачити його повітряну
акробатику
один день із життя чемпіона з
мотофристайлу ванні одара в лігурі
[музика]
краса цього виду спорту в тому що навіть
найбагатша людина у світі не зможе
купити відчуття яке ви переживаєте
пролітаючи у небі поруч зі своїм
мотоциклом
але це не лише про сальто в небесах байк
ванні одара привозить його в
найрізноманітніші місця наприклад у
лікарню в генуї
[музика]
шлях ваннів мотокросі розпочався у 2002
році на забаром він перетворив свої
захоплення на професію І зараз є одними
знаюспішніших у цій галузі його мотоцикл
дає змогу злітати на висоту до 15 метрів
над землею але він завжди відчуває страх
Це те Що змушує тебе рухатися далі
безумовно Це дуже небезпечно Але чим
більше ти тренуєшся і чим більше
стрибаєш тим менше ризиків мотоцикл стає
чимось типу третьої ноги
[музика]
його талант приніс йому славу гроші
успіх і тури по всьому світу від
Бразилії до Росії Але одного разу
поїздка на таксі після перемоги в Москві
змінила усе
відчув сильний запах сечі
Яна гримав на водія щоб він поквапався і
швидше доставив мене до місця
призначення
потім я подивився йому в очі і побачив
чоловіка схожого на мене
Але у нього не було ніг і він сидів там
у власній сечі
і відтоді ванні почав допомагати іншим
Я віддав водієві весь виграш і піднявся
до свого номера у готелі відчувають чи
сором За себе я замислився над тим що
можу зробити щоб допомогти світові
так у нього з'явилась ідея мототерапії
Ідея полягала у тому щоб ділитися своїм
часом і пристрастю з іншими
я б дзвонив асоціації та людей з
обмеженими можливостями і розповів про
свій проект їм сподобалося і Я запросив
їх на змагання в Італії та за кордоном
поїздка на мотоциклі може подарувати
моменти радості чи принаймні можливість
трохи відволіктися людям з інвалідністю
чи хворобою і ця ідея набуває
популярності по всій Італії
Генуя ранок середи в ванній та його друг
метеовіглі як кабує готується відвідати
дитячу лікарню в гасліні Вони відвідують
лікарні з 2014 року
це ніби автостоп
і вибори собі подарунок А тепер Його
черга він ще ніколи не їздив на
мотоциклі
Тримайся міцніше поїхали
на щастя у нас є електромотоцикли тож
діти в лікарні теж можуть ними
насолоджуватися Ми хочемо перетворити це
місце на Великий цирк тому що діти
навіть у лікарні повинні почуватися
дітьми а не пацієнтами
24 маленьких пацієнта чекають на ванні
та його мотоцикл і в онкологічному
відділенні Він приїжджає сюди двічі на
місяць
Як тебе звуть
обережно трубка
раз два три поїхали будьте обережними
[музика]
Я ніколи не думав що мотоцикл може
рухатися так швидко Я відчуваю свою
шкіру своє тіло раптом я подумав
попереду двері Чому він не гальмує а
потім він зробив цю ефектну зупинку це
було фантастично але ванні каже що
незалежно від того наскільки діти
насолоджуються цим завжди залишається
відчуття смутку багато з тих з ким Я
зустрічаюся не виживають це залишає
шрами глибокі рани які ніколи не
загоїться
але візити в ванні дарують маленьким
пацієнтам відчуття радості і надію на те
що незабаром вони знову побачать для
наступної поїздки
а на цьому Ми завершуємо випуск на
нашому сайті ви можете знайти більше
наших історій Дякуємо за перегляд і з
нетерпінням чекаємо на нову зустріч До
побачення
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]